now here's a question for you so how
much responsibility does Hollywood have
to take because they are I wouldn't even
scene say needy they are eyeball deep in
this [ __ ] well the irony is for most I
mean look this is a controversial thing
to say but I think most male actors
would understand it is most guys get
into acting to do sex scenes with girls
I think is that why you wanted to be an
actor no I love the craft and Hollywood
is mired in casting couch and you know
like in theater there's a whole thing
about and touring when you got landlady
does learn lady's daughter does is LD DS
you know in the bottom of guest books
and stuff the whole thing is about
shacking at the end of the day and now
Hollywood has tried to go no it's not
because you know it's been it's been
outed but I think we're guilty I do know
you let you watch the films it like
watch Walter Mitty and something like
that the original Walter Mitty and all
that and see how powerful and strong
those female characters are and how you
you get a sort of sense of what the
culture was like and now watch a
Hollywood film of which I find it quite
tricky unless you know I'm dragged to
watch one and none of it has any
chemistry you're really lacking
chemistry because everyone's sort of
stuck in it kind of no this is as the
woman in this I'm going to be like this
and as the man in this I'm going to be
like this people are constantly trying
to second-guess themselves
I think films are better when they're
you know when they're made by talented
people who aren't trying to make a point
or they're trying to make a decent
political point like the Joker or
something like that which is the last
film I could be bothered to watch did
you watch it yeah what do you think of
it I'm stunning brilliant movie it's so
nice to most interesting is the response
to it from the Twitter going auntie fire
or their dis so they're that and it's
like no it's just a story and it's
beautifully told an extremely dark and
they're bringing fairy tales up and
giving them to adults you know it makes
Michael Keaton's Batman may not aged
that well I don't think it has aged that
well has it so you know it's just become
an adult
adult basting ya Hollywood's
hypocritical we all are oh absolutely a
woman who started off with orgies in
Greece didn't it that's how it all
started the theater people bang each
other real difference in the industry
between post me to and preemie - was it
like a sizable change it depends on the
person when I do when I do sex scenes
are anything with somebody I'm just out
of pure natural like politeness
generally I know what are you cool with
there see you know what what is anything
you don't want to date when we talk it
through because it's also a deeply
unsexy thing today where sex scene
weirdly but now you get an intimacy
coordinator at work
what's that leave you ever see a sex
scene you get an intimacy cool now what
do they do they coordinator of intimacy
how do they do that they they talk you
through it you know so so that is and
that I presume is done legally so that
if there is any pushback on the street
and I go hang on we hide this particular
person and then everything was
everything went fine but what but also
where does that where does the where's
the barrier between I mean obviously but
like I'm saying it was very easy for me
to work with a woman or in some cases a
man and do interviews enough because I'm
like you were right with them okay you
know and you chat it through and then
it's not shock but if you've got I don't
know you credible so you want a bit of a
free
seong even in even if it's pretend
because otherwise she'll just spot it
it'll look very mechanical we don't know
that's the problem I think we just don't
know how there's obviously a problem
between men and women and how we are
engaging I don't happen to think it's
all men I think it's probably a small
minority of men like most things like
there's a small minority of a very nasty
women who do their bit but we're
allowing the minority to dominate their
general conversation by trying to
obliterate everything and normalize
everything and turn everything into
OneNote so that we all we're all the
same it's it's equality of outcome isn't
it that's what they're after
well you need just a balance thank you
probably is important to say that people
are Harvey Weinstein have done is
horrific yeah and none of us would
condone that and I think it's fair to
say that has been a problem in that
environment where you have these massive
power disparities and lots of people
want to be actors just like lots of
people want to be comedians and if there
is beautiful women and powerful men and
the power disparity that will often
result in that kind of situation but
again as you say it's a minority he was
you know I I know somebody who's been in
that situation and they knew exactly
what was happening really quickly and
they got out of it you know
so it's horrific and it's totally wrong
and I hope anyone who does that their
full weight of the law comes down right
on top of them but again there are
people that aren't doing that there are
you know that there is a chemistry
between people you know you do you have
chemistry between people all the time
and we're trying to obliterate that and
I think it's bad and I'll obviously be
shot down for saying that because it
just makes sense made the more you get
shot down in this interview the better
as well
[Music]
but one thing that always again why does
it surprise me it's Hollywood but just
the sheer hypocrisy of going back to the
Weinstein situation where you have all
these people coming out and going what
you did was discussing an awful and of
course it is and it was but then you saw
the pictures of them in the awards
ceremonies big classic grins on their
faces arms around them and you're like
you're telling me you didn't know there
are two years ago but now you've
suddenly and god forbid are there people
that have condemned people like that and
quietly got where they wanted to get you
know do those people exist that have
have you know kept themselves quite
quiet and climb the ladder that way I'm
certain there are you know in the same
way it is it's the is the invisibility
it's notice they're kind of impunity
people up to their own ridiculousness
but showbiz is particularly bad that way
you know
[Music]